je suis à envier et je vous accueille
dans le cadre d'une formation à
destination des femmes futurs
entrepreneurs
moi j'aimerais bien qu'on parle de la
prochaine de briques ce pourquoi vous
êtes doué donc je restitue vous êtes
doué
vous êtes connu à travers notre réseau
vos amis donc fatalement on vous dit que
vous avez un bon relationnel vous mettez
en réseau des gens et ça ça fait partie
des éléments pour lesquels vous êtes le
plus beau être reconnu là dessus
la prochaine étape c'est ce que vous
aimez par exemple quand tu vas nous
disait que le développement personnel
l'a découvert ça et en faire ça lui
plaît vous faites des recherches vous
êtes toujours en veille là-dessus l'osi
de vous améliorer soumia ksa pouvoir
qu'est ce que vous aimez ces trois là
transmission la transmission elle se
sent donc ça si je pense qu'il faut
développer là dessus parce que c'est ce
qui va qui reflète en fait vos valeurs
et vos ambitions dans votre projet entre
pour la dame on se pose trop de
questions et le fait de se poser des
questions en fait ça à vous mais leur
situation d'immobilisme où on ne passe
pas à l'action donc quel statut choisir
comment je les concilier ma vie ma vie
de maman et ma vitre ma vie de futurs
entrepreneurs comment je vais faire pour
ma retraite comment toutes ces questions
a en fait la plupart à lille et ses
questions à qui vous empêche de passer à
l'action un homme ce faux sera pas les
mêmes questions la jdc simple est là on
est nous on est là et petit à petit on
élargit sa zone de confort et grâce à
l'action qu'on compte qu'on va avoir
encore plus et de conclure dîner parfait
tu vois
c'est aussi le perfectionnisme du fait
de on contrôle tout y donc tout soit
parfait tu vois ça ça n'existe pas dans
votre première action elle sera dure au
moins grave que la 15e action